I have our own screenplays for 10 years
however for the first perhaps six of
them I was sort of mucking around with
novels which had strong leads with
poetry I thought I was journalist I
thought I was you know going to do PR
and then one thing led to another the
recession kind of killed most of those
other things and we got married and we
moved a lot and I I discovered it was
anything that really gave me joy I was
free writing I am working on a romantic
comedy that's what I write I write
romantic comedies that is set in a in
Cairo in the grand perimeter in red
ground let's see a starter in 2014 in
august of 2014 however I did we all had
a baby early 2015 and I was working on
other projects as well so all told about
9 or romantic comedies is um that's er
that's an interesting one because let's
see I decided I was a stand-up comedian
in college and I came back to Dubai and
did stand-up comedy
company I just generally like making
people laugh so that's what I thought I
wanted to do and as I got into writing
screenplays I thought yes i'm going to
write comedies i'm gonna like dark
comedies and somehow for some reason it
just wasn't gelling or it wasn't tell
the the projects i was working on wasn't
one they weren't really working and then
i realized that i am a hopeless romantic
and perhaps both of them should um
coalesce does it work romantic comedy
drama romance and complete all romantic
comedy so that's why romantic comedy and
the pyramid well I'm a huge fan of
movies like Indiana Jones and romantic
element that is kind of the bee story in
romantic comedy manga movies the romance
is the a story and the adventure and the
sci-fi elements are the backdrop for
that romance to unfold realizing the
rich of romantic comedy is one thing
which younger changes the structure
completely or perhaps that there's a
there's a there's an expected
tribal to a structure which I totally
so that's been a huge breakthrough and
well does the usual psychological stuff
with anyone
by your romantic comedies and one
interested in a romantic idea he needs
all people of color so one Egyptian one
Indian and their daughter was half
egyptian army um yeah will anyone be
interested in that of course people are
but with the industry being this
interested is really so but really I am
I just loved right in the story so
except it's I've taken a long time to
get took this place but I really don't
mind if nobody's interested because I'm
enjoying writing this story so much
fantastic and that kind of answers my
next question because what's kept it
going I guess you answered that in the
last bit and industries as well oh the
teams in the in the in the movie our ego
and creativity and faith and religion
and how you express your religion in
your daily life what's the right way is
there a right way to to be a believer so
those are very exciting things for me
yes they sound very heavy but already
I'm going to handle them in a much
lighter I've always just finish it and
fish to be um what I what I hope it can
be right um beyond that I mean the usual
stuff I suppose
win a contest get representation get
directed by an awesome team get produced
rather by an awesome team get worldwide
acclaim in an Oscar I say patients
willingness to fail there's something I
think you might have mentioned it to me
sometime ago called a concept called
rapid prototyping you fail fast and fail
often you try a whole lot
what works and continuing to innovate is
a very exciting process to not being
afraid of failure when when my son is
sleeping sniper unit sandwich I sleep
train like a crazy person so not like a
treasonous maybe a little crazy but yeah
when he's keeping which thankfully is
pretty regularly because I am a person
of color when I don't want to those
romantic comedies to have diverse casts
to be in diverse settings um because
love happens all over the world and I
want them I want the movies to reflect
that then they actually a Eureka moment
perhaps two months ago when I realized
oh I'm a romantic comedy writer so ah
it's it's been with till now up until
now i think i've just been learning
because i wrote I wrote a whole bunch of
shorts in various genres and I've
written for features three of which are
pretty much for the chopping block so
I think that I'm starting only now I got
into the second round of the Sundance
screenwriters lab with the first 10
pages okay
selected as one of Jeff flirty lips
selected ten last year was that lost you
know two years ago 2014 so those would
have been the highlights of one a bunch
of little contests on going to the story
on the word in the story block which has
helped a lot with my education just all
of the free resources are helping a lot
self teaching myself encouraged to
onwards and upwards I hope